biggest murder mystery of all time wide
why did Ryan Johnson cook up for just to
upset me oh we all know why that's so
funny seeing you upset I cook them
because they're delicious
yes the interview over
[Music]
nods out is the upcoming whodunit with a
killer cast and here to talk about it
right our director Brian Johnson thank
you good to see you
you've had this idea for a knives out
for 10 years yeah it all came from me
being just a big Agatha Christie fan
ever since I was a little kid and I love
a good whodunit it's just like the most
fun type of book the most fun type of
movie you have like a weird eccentric
detective you have a big fun cast of
like suspects it's kind of self-aware
and fun but it's still a good mystery I
mean it's just it's one of my favorite
things in the world I saw knives out at
TIFF it's fantastic I don't understand
how your brain works because it's it's
so good how many times did you go back
to because I feel like that's like this
these are one of these movies where you
have to make it really airtight yeah you
have to kind of and the thing is like
even you do all the work and you get it
like as irritated as you possibly can
and then every time an actor would come
up to me on set and I could see in their
eyes they had a question my heart would
stop because I like Michael Shannon is
gonna ask me the thing that I'm gonna
not have an answer for and the whole
thing's gonna write the whole thing does
it make sense
yeah it's one of those genres you have
to as much as possible make sure that
the whole thing diagrams out and works
but that's fun yeah that's kind of the
fun part I'm writing wise I think yeah
yeah the tougher thing is making all the
characters kind of you know giving you
have cast with that many amazing people
you want to make sure everybody has
enough to do in it and that is kind of
the harder thing is making sure everyone
gets their moment how fun was it filming
that scene there's a couple scenes like
that and what's fun about is not just
Captain America getting telling everyone
to eat poopoo what's was fun is all
those actors in the same room at once
playing a big scene with all of them
together so you have Jamie Lee Curtis
and Toni Collette and Michael Shannon
and Chris Evans and Kathryn Langford and
everybody everybody jumping on especial
seemed like that where they're all
basically having a big fight with each
other they are just like having the time
of their lives and so I got unset I just
got the lake sit back and just have a
huge smile on my face at the monitor he
was pretty cool how was it the party pre
my dad's death it was great
Jamie Lee Curtis like I she was one of
those people I was like almost nervous
to me cuz I was like I want this toast
you weren't you weren't I wasn't so
nervous yeah it's like I don't think I
get like nervous and more than I'm like
I just like I'm like if this goes bad
like it's gonna I'm gonna be so sad she
was the coolest freakin person amazing
yes yeah she's just got that sort of
she's so smart she's got such a I was
made to say she's got like an alpha nerd
energy she's like she's so on top of
everything she's so engaged and yet
she's also like she'd the stuff that
she's into and the stuff she gets
excited about it it's just like we can
talk about things for hours she's
awesome and she's so good that she's
good she's got I mean comedy chops like
just through the ceiling yeah obviously
and so she had the blast in this she I
interviewed her on a carpet and she
rearranged the carpet so that I would be
out of the Sun that's her she would so
we were shooting in this big mansion you
know in Massachusetts and basically the
whole thing took place in that house so
in every morning first of all she would
be early she would beat all of us there
just said second of all she basically
everyone else would like go down into
the green room into like the hangout
where all their chairs were they had
their names on Jamie would go straight
to the kitchen and she just ended up
hanging out with a house owner in the
kitchen and she eventually ended up
putting her lunch in the fridge and then
by the end of the shoot she was like
baking cookies in the kitchen and had
like taken over the house baby oh my god
and then she would show up on set early
and not in sometimes she would show up
on set when she wasn't even supposed to
be in the scene and just be hanging out
and I would get really confused and then
nervous Jamie Lee Curtis is here look
film her and so she got into scenes she
wasn't even supposed to be in just just
because she was there that's amazing
lessons that's a good tip right don't
show up to work when I'm not even
supposed to be here
you have an all-star cast you've given
the chance to send one of them to a
galaxy far far away
who are you sending oh my god I want to
take everybody can I get Jamie Lee
Curtis and oh my god I don't think it
would be tough I feel like she would
just pack her but you ain't in pack her
bag she just show up and go be there
okay yeah sure love you gonna be like
you know what you're gonna get to space
and she'll be there yes so what is the
latest on your your Star Wars trilogy
we're an update for us no I got no
update if in an interview and people
went crazy
did I say if you said and then people
were like the same are ya no no I have
no I have no update at all I bet ya I'm
still still working with Lucasfilm on
there then they're figuring out what
when they do what and everything but
yeah no update well get away from your
family this Thanksgiving go see knives
out in theaters November 27th thank you
so much thank you
[Music]